this would be the legend of the black
Shu According to some lore it's believed
that the black Shu was a dog that
originally died in a fire and the dog's
ghost was then said to roam Europe
terrorizing people along the way
according to the BBC in the 1500s there
were over 500 reported sightings of the
black Shu it was said to be a hellhound
in fact the word shuck is believed to be
derived from the old English word Sucka
meaning devil she's described as a
ferocious Hound with pitch black fur
ranging anywhere in size from a large
dog to a small horse he's sometimes
recounted with big glowing red eyes
occasionally characterized with just one
huge red eyee in the middle of his
forehead the spectral Beast is known for
stalking and intimidating his human
victims the BBC article states that in
1577 one documented case in bleber
reported that a snarling Beast broke
into a church rampaged through the
congregation and bit the necks of two
people who promptly dropped a DE